if you look at the two photo play medal
winners prior to Robin Hood they were
very small
films humoresque tol'able David Robin
Hood was a blockbuster and that really
was the first to establish this idea of
what we now call a blockbuster or a
tentpole film and to do it so
artistically was really quite a
marvelous thing and the industry
appreciated Robin Hood because it
galvanized the industry after a terrible
slump there had been a succession of
scandals there really was a financial
meltdown in Hollywood and Robin Hood put
the industry most of it back to work and
it reanalyzed the film industry and
because it was done with such style by
somebody who was of quality I suppose
the story that I like best about Robin
Hood because so many of the stories
about anything about Fairbanks or Robin
Hood is apocryphal but this one is true
we can verify it is that Douglas
Fairbanks was so terribly proud of his
set it was the largest set ever built in
Hollywood still the largest it was 90
feet tall that Norman English castle and
Fairbanks being Fairbanks had to show it
off like a big kid so he brought his
friends around and amongst them was
Charlie Chaplin and Charlie Chaplin
looked at this huge set with this
enormous drawbridge and said to his
friend Douglas Fairbanks Doug I'd like
to use this in one of my comedies and
Fairbanks thought of this austere big
enormous set and what could it be for a
comedy so he said what were you thinking
charlie and Charlie said I'll show you
so Charlie got behind this a big draw
bridge and then wait a minute and then
the drawbridge came slowly down of this
huge castle and Charlie came out in a
nightshirt with his cat underneath his
arm with an empty milk bottle and he put
out the cat put out the milk bottle
scratched himself is he ready to go to
bed and walk back and the huge
drawbridge just sort of raised up it was
a marvelous comedy idea and but
Fairbanks was too astute of producer to
let this huge enormous piece of property
be used in another film so it was it was
never used a real loss to film comedy I
think it would been awfully funny
you